bootleg cat podcast
Jen Carter we just did a crazy interview
we're about to try coffee for the first
time but before we do that we're gonna
have
these young superstars from Brooklyn do
what they do
the 41 compilation out right now come on
[Music]
push me away with all of you the hardest
you my brother I got you regardless I
don't care about what that [__] doing
like in the I know we going to fathers
God he said what the with the B1 of
Ruger probably on a Ruger right be ready
to order this order to the top to cook
for maneuver and this life I feel like I
don't know what the [__] am I doing and
I try not to think about the [__] you
[__] my motor
I'm not a loser don't say I need a money
is smoother drinking the promise away
[__] everybody and [__] all the rumors
shipping quickly forgot it was mud I
don't cry so I couple with drugs like I
don't know where my time gonna come I'm
at the bottom back where I have a gun
feeling weak but I gotta be strong like
only for love when I'm gone but put me
up [__] all the pain like what my
channel
God
right there
KO yes sir 41 appreciate y'all crazy hey
I know you just watched the new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-d-g.com promo code bootleg and save
30 off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week